I've talked to lots of business people
about leadership and there's a
literature on leadership but it's not a
good literature it's it's pretty shallow
partly because it's not that easy to
define leadership and partly because
there are different you know you people
have different temperaments and
different temperaments can be leaders
they just do it in different ways
now there's something in common about
being a leader though and I would say
one is that if you're an actual leader
you actually know where you're going
right because what are you gonna do lead
people in circles it's like maybe
they'll follow you but you're not a
leader you're just a charlatan so you
have to know where you're going and then
you have to be able to communicate that
and then people have to trust you so you
actually have to be honest because
people aren't that stupid at least not
for a long period of time and then where
you're going has to have some value
because otherwise why would anyone want
to go along with you so and then you
might say well what what are the
attributes then that make you a leader
and I would say well they're
characterological fundamentally and this
is not naive optimism or or or casual
moralizing it has nothing to do with
that you know we know for example that
conscientiousness that the personality
trait is a good predictor of long-term
success in in most occupations not all
but most and that one of the things
that's associated with conscientiousness
is that people keep their word they're
trustworthy and that's certainly one
element of a leader especially across
any reasonable amount of time you have
to be able to trust the person they can
even be harsh right it doesn't matter
because you can see harsh leaders and
kind leaders but as long as they do what
they say they will do then then you can
follow them and you know that the future
payoff is is is secure something like
that so the idea that characterological
development is more important to
leadership than primogenitor
I think that's the right word primal
Genesis anyways being a firstborn that's
a very crucial psychological realization
that it's character logical development
that makes you favored of God you know
and I do think we've forgotten this in
many ways because there isn't a lot of
emphasis in our education system on
characterological development and that's
very very surprising to me I think maybe
it's partly because in our fractured
society we can't agree on what
constitutes a reasonable
characterological goal so we just throw
up our hands and don't educate our kids
to any degree at all especially in
schools about what an admirable person
is like or even let them know that well
maybe you should actually try to be one
you know that that's actually the most
important possible thing that you could
learn right
[Applause]